monsieur michel r merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à la
ministre de l'éducation nationale madame
la ministre chaque fois que l'opposition
vous questionne dans cet hémicycle vous
faites avec avec votre objectivité
légendaire un bilan élogieux du
quinquennat de françois hollande en
matière d'éducation
vous êtes la seule à le faire qui
d'autre en effet oserait chanter les
louanges des trois ministres qui se sont
succédés en cinq ans au ministère de
l'éducation nationale
certainement pas les parents
certainement pas les enseignants qui
garderont un goût amer des promesses non
tenues et de la brutalité avec laquelle
vos réformes ont été menées
je pensais la désastreuse réforme des
rythmes scolaires qui a été imposé aux
enseignants aux familles et aux communes
contre leur avis et qui s'est fait au
détriment des enfants fatigue accrue des
élèves absentéisme en hausse réduction
des temps d'apprentissage en maternelle
au cp inégalités entre les communes dans
l'offre des activités périscolaires
c'est cela le vrai bilan de la réforme
de monsieur peillon même échec à propos
de la réforme des collèges que vous avez
fait passer en force contre l'opinion
très majoritaire des professeurs
même benoît hamon veut très éphémère
prédécesseur qui n'a même pas eu le
temps d'effectuer une rentrée scolaire a
déploré qu'il y a eu pour cette réforme
je cite une forme de brutalité dans sa
mise en oeuvre qui aboutit à son
inefficacité
on ne saurait mieux dire une récente
enquête de bv à souligner que plus de 9
par an sur dix réclament que l'école
serait forme
enfin ce qui traduit à niveau
d'insatisfaction considérable alors que
françois hollande avait promis de
refonder l'école
alors madame la ministre à l'heure du
bilan au lieu de pratiquer comme à
chaque fois l'auto satisfaction ou la
critique du précédent quinquennat
pourquoi ne vous aspirez vous pas de la
méthode de votre ancien collègue du
gouvernement emmanuel macron qui
pratiquent désormais la culture de
l'excusé que regrettez-vous de quoi vous
excusez vous et que feriez-vous
maintenant jade vallaud belkacem
ministre de l'éducation nationale de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député herbillon cette
dernière semaine de législature est
l'occasion de tirer un bilan non pas du
quinquennat qui est loin d'être terminée
mais de la qualité du travail engagé
avec le mans en je veux donc commencé
par remercier très chaleureusement tous
ceux d'entre vous qui ont contribué à
adopter la loi de refondation de l'école
tous ceux d'entre vous qui ont voté les
budgets pour l'éducation nationale et en
ont fait la première priorité de notre
nation qu'ils sachent que c'est grâce à
qu'aujourd'hui des professeurs en nombre
sont revenus devant les classes des
professeurs qui sont désormais formés
grâce à la reconstruction de leur
formation qui sont désormais mieux
rémunérés qu'ils sachent que c'est grâce
à eux que des enfants en situation de
handicap sont aujourd'hui 30% de plus à
être accueillis dans nos écoles par
rapport à 2012
qu'ils sachent que c'est grâce à eux si
nous avons réduit le nombre de
décrocheurs scolaires de 140000 à 98
milles en cinq ans qu'ils sachent que
c'est grâce à eux si les résultats
scolaires ce améliore notablement dans
les allées les collèges de l'éducation
prioritaire aussi encore 75 % des
enfants aujourd'hui bénéficient
d'activités périscolaires contre 25% en
monsieur le député herbillon je suis
beaucoup plus dubitative cela ne vous
étonnera pas quant à l'apport de ceux
qui comme vous n'ont voté ni la loi de
fondation de l'école ni les budgets
leurs électeurs n'ont pas eu à en
souffrir car nos investissements bien
été fait sur tout le territoire guidé
par le seul intérêt des élèves mais je
me demande simplement et sincèrement si
vous avez le sentiment du devoir
accompli quand vos questions or ont
consisté pour l'essentiel à traiter les
décrocheurs scolaires de paresseux a
déploré qu'on dépense comme pour
l'éducation à faire la promotion de
l'école privée à jeter sans arrêt
l'anathème sur nos professeurs me
le député la réponse est dans la
question merci madame la ministre